naomi klein if you don't mind I'm gonna
just read a couple of paragraphs from
your Wikipedia site and have you comment
on okay Naomi Klein born May 8 1970
Montreal Quebec as a Canadian journalist
author and activist known for her
political analysis and criticism of
corporate globalization do you like that
lead I think that's fair enough
yeah sure III don't call it
globalization myself when he called well
I think I'm a critic of corporate power
whether locally or globally and the term
globalization I've never found all that
helpful but it's good that they put the
corporate ahead of it so it isn't just
being against the world as you know this
is written by people we don't know and
comes together cloud have you ever
looked at it no I don't know I have this
I have this allergy okay let me keep
breathe okay I mean climb was brought up
in a Jewish family with a history of
left-wing activism her parents moved to
Montreal Canada from the USA in 1967 as
war resisters to the Vietnam War
her mother a documentary filmmaker
Bonnie sure Cline cher cher is best
known for her anti-pornography film not
a love story that's true her father
Michael Kline is a physician and a
member of physicians for Social
Responsibility her brother Seth Kline is
director of the British Columbia office
of the Canadian Center for Policy
Alternatives let's just go back over
that family of trouble well tell the
story about how your parents where do
they come from in the States
my father was born in Newark New Jersey
and my mother was born in Philadelphia
they both went to Stanford for grad
school and met there and my grandparents
my father's parents are also were also
activists my my grandfather was actually
a union organizer without at Walt Disney
he was an animator he used to draw
Donald Duck for Walt Disney he was in
charge of Donald Duck continuity which
to make sure that that Donald Duck
always appeared the same in every
cartoon he worked on Fantasia
worked on some fantastic Disney films
but in the 1940s he was one of he was
one of one of several union organizers
and they staged the first animator
strike and he got fired and blacklisted
and and and because of this history of
black listening in the family my for my
father was drafted to go to Vietnam he
didn't want to go he had a he was a
pacifist it continues to be a pacifist
but he also didn't want to go through
the process of proving his political
credentials because of the history of
the house on American Activities and
the the political resonance in his own
family of having been the son of a black
listed artist so I just preferred to
leave and came to Canada and that's why
I'm Canadian I was born a few years
later your mother were they married here
um they were married in in New Jersey
yeah and then they never can they move
together my I have an older brother
where did they move to to Montreal and
they still there no they are now in
Vancouver for the weather but they moved
to Montreal many American many American
young people in this time moved to
Canada there was something of a brain
drain our universities are filled with
with war resisters from the Vietnam era
my father got a job teaching at McGill
teaching medicine at McGill my mother
worked at the National Film Board of
Canada and in fact we moved back to the
United States when I was a baby and
lived there till I was five in Rochester
New York
and this was you know after it had
become safe for war resisters to return
to the United States and and and my
father worked in a health clinic in the
States and my mother worked at a cable
access channel and they both decided
that they actually preferred it in
Canada where my father could work in the
public health care system we have a
single-payer national health care
program and my father preferred that and
my mother was was working for the
National Film Board which was is a
public institution that that allowed her
to make the kind of political films that
she wanted to make so
they left left the us because of of the
war in Vietnam but they stayed in Canada
because really because of the social
programs did when do you remember when
you first learned this story and it sunk
in I feel like I always knew this story
about about health care I was five when
we moved back and it was explained to me
in fairly simple terms that we were
moving back to Canada because because in
Canada you didn't have to be rich to get
sick I mean this was explained to me you
know as a kid that and I did understand
it that it was really unfair that my
father felt it was really unfair that
people were denied access to medicine
because they didn't have money to pay
and as a doctor he preferred to work in
a system where money didn't have
anything to do with the quality of
health care that you received and I feel
like I I feel like I've always known
that yeah and it's always been a part of
my of my Canadian identity my Canadian
identity has always been really tied to
these things that made I mean I have I
have an identity as a Canadian and as an
American I have dual citizenship we it
was only our little nuclear family that
moved to Canada my grandparents on both
sides were in the United States all of
my cousins are still in the United
States so we were always going back and
forth over the border but I was always
aware of the things that made Canada
different and and you know it had to do
with our foreign policy the fact that
Canada wasn't involved in Vietnam didn't
have sent troops to Vietnam that we had
a prime minister pierre trudeau at the
time who declared the Canada would be it
would be a haven for people who were
resisting the war and the fact that we
did have different values when it came
to to healthcare and and and how to
treat people who were sick so it was
really formative for me that these
choices my parents made how did you get
dual citizenship and are they did they
have dual yeah you oughta both my
parents are American they didn't lose
their citizenship when they moved to
Canada
Carter pardoned to the war resisters and
if your parents are both American you
you're American no matter where you are
born so I have but I was born in Canada
so because I was born in Canada
automatically have Canadian citizenship
and because both my parents are American
I I also have American citizenship go
back to what you said about your
grandfather being blacklisted who
blacklisted him well you know these were
these were the times Walt Disney himself
testified against the strike organizers
before the house of America activities
and you know the blacklist was
unofficial but what happened is he just
couldn't get work as an artist he
couldn't get work as an artist so he he
painted signs he worked in the shipyards
but he wasn't able to work in the
profession that he loved and which in
which he possessed enormous talent which
was as an animator it wasn't always
interesting to me that despite the fact
that his you know career was really
ruined by by Walt Disney and he wasn't
the only one he still loved films and he
used to delight us as kids drawing
drawing no perfect caricatures of all
the of all the Disney characters and you
know we watched the films that he helped
animate with great pride so we always
had sort of made a distinction between
the fact that the films could be
wonderful
even if the the corporate politics of
the company were not so wonderful and I
think that really helped inform how I
wrote wrote about about pop culture and
and and how I wrote no logo which was I
think a lot of people who who certainly
of my parents generation who write about
pop culture and mass culture tend to
throw it all out you know throwing out
the or anyone who wants to go to the
mall you know it has just has terrible
values and it's just junk or there
wasn't there was a sort of disdain for
for pop culture and and for me I felt
like it was possible to critique the
corporate power but still maintain an
appreciation of why we're drawn to this
culture let me keep reading someone will
be redundant her paternal grandparents
were communists who began to turn
against the Soviet Union after the
Molotov Ribbentrop pact and had
abandoned communism by 1956 in 1942 her
grandfather Phil Kline and animator
Disney was far
as an agitator after the Disney
animators strike and went to work at a
shipyard instead client's father grew up
surrounded by ideas of social justice
and racial equality but found it quote
difficult and frightening to be the
child of Communists unquote a so-called
red diaper baby all that true um yeah
but pretty much true I don't know the
the exact years offhand and I would
always double-check Wikipedia
I know but did you talk to him your
father about this you know that
frightened about well that's what I was
saying earlier about you know what
really why he came to Canada that this
feeling that the the state was was
watching and and this fear of you know I
think he's in order to be a
conscientious objector you have to prove
your credentials and I think that for
having been that the child of a
blacklisted man it was just too close to
half for him to think about proving his
familial credentials as a leftist as as
a pacifist and and the idea of of of
turning on his family of giving the
state information that they would use
against people he loved so he just
preferred to leave
I hear the Canadian accident against oh
yeah things like that are you aware that
I know most people tell me I have very
very neutral accent yeah
anyway this one go on for every but I
wanted a couple more paragraphs Klein's
husband avi Lewis comes from a similar
leftist background he is a TV journalist
and a documentary filmmaker his parents
are the writer and activist Michelle
Landsberg and politician and diplomat
Stephen Lewis
son of David Lewis one of the founders
of the Canadian New Democratic Party son
intern of Moshe Lewis born glose a
jewish labor activist of the bund who
left eastern europe for canada in 1921
how we done this is feeling a little bit
like the house is this is your Wikipedia
site which you know like people don't
really have
troll over there we I know what are you
thinking so far is this good or bad
well I think this sort of obsession with
my family history is a little bit
bizarre you know it's it's not an area
that I've written on you know I write
about politics and culture I'm not an
autobiographical writer so it's sort of
interesting to me that this is the most
seen as the most interesting thing or
the most relevant thing about me you
know I think it would be if I were a
memoirist you know I may I might write
one of those one day but it's it's not
been what I have done with my life
but we're gonna get yeah but I got a
paragraph about you here and this is
what I want to ask my client spent her
teenage years as a mall rat obsessed
with designer logos as a child and
teenager she found it quote very
oppressive to have a very public
feminist mother unquote and she rejected
politics instead embracing quote full-on
consumerism unquote mm-hmm yeah that Poe
is what passed his rebellion in my
family in the 1980s we used to joke that
I was like Mallory on Family Ties I
don't know if you remember that show but
it was these these two sort of aging
hippie parents who produced this mall
rat daughter and of course a wall street
watching son so we were sort of
reenacting that in our family home a
little bit in the 80s it was the 80s
after all what about a very public
feminist mother did that bother you at
the time and how was your public oh well
she was a filmmaker and and she made
films about the women's movement she was
part of this studio called studio D that
was part of the National Film Board of
Canada was the first women's film studio
and you know I actually I've been very
much influenced by my mother and and and
her ideas about about media and culture
because studio D was this was this was
this film center that saw itself as sort
of the film arm of the women's movement
right and then with the women's the
moon's movement was in high gear this
was the early 70s and the film world was
extremely male-dominated so they made
the argument that they need
a special studio to to nurture and
mentor young women filmmakers but the
films they made were sort of films that
were consciousness-raising films they
were they were films that were meant
that were sort of watched in in living
rooms and people would watch them and
and and and and it would change their
lives and they would see it and you know
this was this was the second second wave
feminism this was happening with books
it was happening with films but yeah I
learned a lot from from growing up
around that and seeing how how books and
films can be part of movements and
should be part of the movements any any
any powerful movement has has culture
and deeply embedded in it so yeah I
think that was an important
counterbalance for me getting a sort of
more traditional journalism training you
know my mother would told me when I got
my first real journalism job at The
Globe and Mail which is you know a
fairly conservative newspaper in Canada
that's where I interned and got my first
job she told me that would people say
that that I lack objectivity it means I
object to your activity and she always
felt that you could be fair you could
you could you could tell both sides of
the story but that the most honest thing
that you could do is admit that you have
a point of view and and that that a
passion for the subject fuels your work
but yeah I guess being in you know in
grade six having a mother who was really
out there on some controversial subjects
like pornography was you know not ideal
I from the perspective of a you know of
a preteen but there were wonderful
things about it as well why did she feel
so strongly about pornography you'd have
to ask her yeah did she ever tell you we
you know I was so young when she made
the film she made the film she made lots
of films you know it wasn't a lifelong
obsession you know she would she would
you know like like a lot of filmmakers
know she would become obsessed with the
subject for a couple of years and move
on she certainly had had a
has has had a consistent commitment to
human rights in her work but pornography
was just one you know one interest of
hers and it was just that it was a very
sensational topic it was the height of
the anti-porn movement and so she got
really attacked for this film but no
it's not really a conversation I've had
with her
this goes on to get into her mother had
a stroke and became severely disabled at
when you were 17 when you were preparing
to go to the University of Toronto
Naomi along with her father and brother
took care of bonny so much your mother's
name through the period in the hospital
and at home making educational
sacrifices to do so that year off
stopped her quote from being such a brat
quote how is your mother today
she's good she's good and she she made a
pretty remarkable recovery she had a -
devastating strokes that turned out that
she had a brain tumor at what age was
she she was 46 and she yeah she was very
very young to be having these types of
debilitating strokes the second stroke
she lost all movement including breath
she was on a respirator she was not
absolutely immobilized for four months
and it turned out that that it wasn't a
normal stroke that actually she had a
brain tumor in in her brain stem that
she'd had her whole life that she didn't
know about it was like a literally a
bomb in the brain and it was made up of
blood vessels and when she reached you
know 46 they burst so you know you can
live your whole life and not and not
know that you have this sort of time
bomb so they were able to operate on it
and at an excellent Hospital at the
University of Ontario of Western Ontario
she was airlifted from Montreal they did
this life-saving surgery and she's made
a remarkable recovery she she she walks
with two canes she she has a tricycle
that she bikes on and she made a film
about disability in the arts recently
her first film since the stroke so she's
doing great
what did you do about your education did
you did you ever get it yeah I went to
school I just took a year off school
yeah and took care of my mom and get it
then I went to the University of Toronto
and your degrees in what I studied
philosophy and literature but I actually
left when I got offered this job at The
Globe and Mail there was an election can
went for as a summer intern and I had a
couple of credits left and then there
was an election campaign pretty sort of
hot election campaign and they asked me
to stay on and I never actually made it
back to school so so your career this
book right here no logo it says in the
Wikipedia piece has sold a million
copies yeah yeah why I think a lot of it
was was the moment when it came out it
came out ten years ago and the book
tracks the the the increasing power of
corporations and and it was a time when
corporations were changing it was the
embracing of this idea of of branding
over the production of goods and this is
something you know I I after I left the
Global Mail I started writing a column
for another newspaper a weekly column
and I was sort of like the token youth
column columnist I've got a column I'd
like something silly like age 23 or
something like that and so I was I was
um that was my beat you know young
people and so I was looking at all kinds
of different things the kind of jobs
young people were getting the kind of
culture we were consuming the issues
that we cared about and obviously gross
generalizations the whole idea of being
a youth spokesperson has vaguely absurd
but you know it was a great platform to
explore different subjects and there
were these themes that were emerging in
my columns one of them was the
increasing casualization of work the
fact that my generation of workers out
of university we're not getting offered
jobs we were getting offered contracts
and this was a real change from the
previous generation it was something
that's so obvious now but ten years ago
really was a shift it really was a
phenomenon and we were there was also
just an amazing voracious 'no sin the
world of marketing a amazing
aggressiveness so spaces that had
previously been totally off limits to
corp
relations were being infiltrated so at
the high school level there was a
company called channel 1 which was
getting televisions into the classrooms
and with advertisements in them which
was just you know creating a huge
scandal so I was covering that and the
first sort of fast-food outlets in on
university campuses on public university
campuses more and more corporate
sponsored research on university
campuses because public funding was
collapsing in Canada the there's no
there are no private universities
everything's public but it was becoming
increasingly sort of public in name only
because corporations were making these
inroads so I decided to make there are
no private universities in Canada no we
have a the public edge but there are
some private post-secondary education
education institutions like colleges but
not you at the university level yeah I
don't mean interact that's alright and
so I decided to write no logo when I was
started to read about this mismanagement
phenomenon of telling corporations that
they should sell off their factories and
invest in their image and their brands
and it seemed to make sense of these two
trends that I had been following at once
the fact that increasingly corporations
were less interested in the world of
work that they were outsourcing and
subcontracting everything that they
could you know creating what was being
called at the time hollow corporations
companies like Nike that were they
didn't own a single factory but yet were
this this shoe an athletic giant but
we're incredibly aggressive in their
marketing so what I discovered was that
this increasingly aggressive marketing
and this and this increasingly casual
work that was being offered were
actually two sides of the same coin so
that's when I that's when I wrote no
logo and and it was the first book to to
really bring these trends together but
it also I also was arguing that because
corporations are making less of a
commitment to young people as employers
and people are less loyal to
corporations he may be loyal to a brand
as a
but that's different than the kind of
loyalty that our parents generation had
to the companies that were offering them
employment for life
ours was a much more fickle loyalty and
it could really turn on a dime so what
in the in in the last half of the book I
target the rise of anti-corporate
activism of young people increasingly
going after companies like Nike for
using sweatshops in the developing world
things like that or a company like shell
for their environmental record in
Nigeria and talking about how branding
was being used against these was being
boomerang back on these corporations so
as I was writing this it took me about
four years to write it you know I would
tell people I'm writing a book that
about the rise of anti-corporate
activism and people say what
anti-corporate activism this was the 90s
these are the boom years this was the
dot-com bubble you know most people
didn't have a you know a bad thing to
say about corporations everything seemed
to be going really well with the free
market economy but the book was at the
printer in November of 1999 exactly ten
years ago and when the World Trade
Organization meeting was held in Seattle
and Seattle was flooded with tens of
thousands of activists many of them
young who were talking about many of
these issues of the environmental record
of the oil companies of the labor
records of companies like Nike and it
really took the mainstream media
completely by surprise and so that the
book success was really about the fact
that it came along at this moment when
this movement came along and came to
sudden consciousness and and the book
got to become part of that movement if I
figure right you were probably about 25
years old when you started writing it
starts turning 26 yeah around there yeah
I did it a you cross your mind that's
awfully young to do something like that
or were you just was just following on a
very active period I mean were you
always an activist no I mean certainly
not in high school um in university I
got involved in in campus politics a
little bit but mostly I was involved in
campus journalism I was the editor of my
university newspaper at the University
of Toronto which was you know full-time
job actually
has it the newspaper came out three
times a week and it's very very large
campus so I was you know I cared a lot
about issues but it wasn't like I was
out there with a picket sign I never was
one for rallies or marches or chanting
but I but I felt and I guess coming from
you know what my mother showed me that
that writing that journalism was was
part of of any movement and and that's
what I you know I think it I'm
University campuses a lot of people feel
that way a lot of a lot of campus
journalism is very activist very
opinionated can you vote both in Canada
and the United States I can if I want to
yeah
have you voted in the United States no I
haven't never know because I don't live
in the United States and I only ever
travel on on my Canadian passport I
don't actually have my an American
passport so if I moved to the US and I
wanted to you know if I lived here then
I would activate all that and certainly
voting elections if I understand it
right I have in my hand the new forward
to your book no logo coming out yeah
yeah in paperback it yeah it's coming
out a 10th anniversary edition with it
with the new forward all right I'm gonna
read you some of what you wrote okay the
problem is that as with many other
lifestyle brands before him his actions
do not come close to living up to the
hopes he has raised Barack Obama mm-hmm
yeah and you know this is what I track
in the book is how the the ambition of
the Superbrands of the 1990s of
companies like Starbucks and and and
Nike and and an Apple where they really
equally equated their brands with these
sort of transcendent ideas and
revolutionary imagery ended up making
them very very vulnerable to to their
consumers demanding more of them right
you know these these you know when a
company like Apple uses Gandhi in an ad
which they did in the 1990s or Nike sort
of uses feminism you know women's
empowerment or your anti racism in there
Marketing it's usually because you know
somebody in in in there at their
advertising firm and it's done a lot of
research and found that this is the
message that's going to be most resonant
with their target market young people
are very very focused on diversity and
and and this will really resonate with
them but they weren't prepared for being
held accountable really accountable for
these ideas where suddenly their
consumers are going you know if you
believe in women's empowerment why are
16 year old girls in Indonesia making
your sneakers for paltry wages why
aren't you paying them a living wage why
aren't you paying them a fair wage and
it's interesting you know it's it's it
really that kind of activism forced a
lot of reform on the on these companies
but I argue in the introduction that the
most significant development in the
world of branding is the application of
this theory of the of the hollow
corporation and all of these ideas about
messaging being totally absorbed into
the world of politics and you know
Barack Obama is certainly the zenith of
this is campaign used absolutely every
tool in the branding arsenal a
tremendous effect there were some
interesting similarities actually
between some of his campaign imagery and
marketing and Nikes campaign campaigns
but now I think we are at a time where a
lot of people who believed in him are
feeling this gap between the emotions
that his campaign raised and I say
emotions because it is it wasn't exactly
promises in a lot of cases and this is
what made his campaign more like
lifestyle marketing than a traditional
political campaign he very studiously
stayed away from really really clear
promises on a lot of topics and more it
did what all great marketers do which is
and create a very broad canvas and and
and create associations with
transformation even with revolution
without actually taking that extra step
of saying I am going to do this this is
exactly how I'm going to change the
world but inviting people to project
what they wanted on to this very very
broad canvas so people sort of have a
feeling that he promised more than he
actually did
and and that's where the feelings of
betrayal come in now where I think you
know his opponents are extremely
mobilized as we know extremely angry but
his supporters are pretty tentative
right now because he and I think he's
got a branding problem I think he's got
the same problem at Nike ad in the 1990s
he he raised hopes and it hasn't been
and hasn't lived up to them I don't
think it's too late for him to do that
but but I really think he has failed to
do that so far did you ever think during
the campaign that you heard something
you wanted to hear from him and did you
believe it absolutely I mean I was I was
conscious of that but because I've
studied marketing so closely you know I
was aware that I was projecting that
that I was that I was I was aware that I
was witnessing very very effective
marketing and you know I knew you know I
didn't but did a fair bit of research
about what what his actual policies were
and and I knew that there was a gap
between the sort of euphoric hopes that
he was what he that he was raising and
what he was actually promising so it
isn't as simple as broken promises
that's that's I think what's also
demobilizing
his base you know a lot of people felt
that obama represented peace you know he
made them feel peace like like like they
were part of an anti-war movement right
you know they were they were sick of
bushes wars and and and it was a very
idealistic spirit of the campaign but if
you actually look at his policies what
he said well he did say it was good
escalate in Afghanistan and he did say
he was no good a drawdown in Iraq but
not pull out completely so his base is
in an awkward position because they
can't say you broke your promise because
actually he did not promise to end the
war in Iraq or Afghanistan and I think
people just don't know how to respond to
this particular type of a campaign which
is so much more like the world of
marketing than it is politics if we
followed you around on a day-to-day
basis what would you be doing
mostly writing and so it wouldn't be
terrifically interesting just to hang
out I guess I should've asked it
differently I mean we read that you're
always in front of audiences traveling a
lot you and your husband separate worlds
and all that
well when the shot when my last book
came out when the Shock Doctrine came
out ya know things went pretty crazy for
me and and the book came out
simultaneously in a lot of different
countries so I was on the road pretty
steadily for almost two years but I put
a lot of research into my books I and
I've only written two two books I did a
collection but they were set seven years
passed between no logo and the Shock
Doctrine so you know I see it in cycles
I think you know I actually really go
into hibernation when I'm writing and in
fact when I wrote the shock doctor and I
left my home in Toronto and went and
lived in a very remote part of British
Columbia was you know in Italy in in the
wilderness no distractions and I think I
was money my husband came with me you
had to go back and forth a fair bit
because he was hosting TV shows in his
spare time but you know I did a lot of
field research for the Shock Doctrine I
went to Iraq I was I was in Sri Lanka
after the tsunami New Orleans after the
flood but when it came down to actually
writing I just totally hauled up so I'm
kind of entering one of those phases now
I'm not I'm doing a lot less public
speak am saying not've isn't a lot and
this is a bit of a rare week for me I'm
kind of coming out of hibernation and
doing a little bit of a little bit of
public public stuff but I'm actually I'm
I'm in research mode where did you meet
avi Lewis actually I knew his family and
you mentioned his mother as his mother's
a wonderful journalist and and and
somebody I respected a great deal and I
you know it's not that big a country so
um I knew where I am and that I'll be
through his mother yeah speaking of the
different country when you're in Canada
do you feel differently than you do when
you're in the United States I mean and
when you interact with people is there a
different attitude and among the
Canadians and there is about
the Americans that country and
patriotism and Wars and all that it
depends so much where where I am in the
United States to be honest with you I
don't feel a huge difference between the
blue parts of the United States and
Canada
I think the countries are coming a
little bit more more and more together
and but no III feel pretty comfortable
in that in going going back and forth
certainly from new york to toronto or
who's the most angry with your writing
well Milton Friedman Franz fans were
pretty angry with the Shock Doctrine
because the book the book is pretty
tough on on Milton Friedman and and I
would say I would I would I think that
there's probably still the people who
are who are most annoyed with certainly
my books why did you pick on Milton
Friedman well the Shock Doctrine tells
an alternative history of how we ended
up with the kind of market economy that
we have and that's been globalized
around the world and it's a it's a
pretty fundamentalist version of market
economics that pretty much everything
should be privatized mania for
deregulation we've seen the results on
Wall Street so so that so the Shock
Doctrine tells the story of how we got
here and Milton Friedman played a pretty
important role in that's in that story
mainly because he was the movement's
prime popularizer not because these his
ideas were so original he was certainly
he was part of the Chicago School
tradition but he took that tradition to
the masses and he was the one with the
column the Newsweek he was the one who
did the 10 part series on PBS
he had that incredible talent for
writing for popular take taking
economics and and and and and bringing
it to a popular audience so he played a
very very important role he was a
political adviser to many governments
but the real the focus of the book is
much less on him personally than then on
on the University of Chicago and the
particular role that the University of
Chicago played
internationally because the University
of Chicago had a very aggressive program
of attracting international students
particularly students from Latin America
and this was actually had nothing to do
with Milton Friedman he it wasn't his
idea to do this was actually a decision
that came out of the State Department
where there was there was a lot of
concern in the 1950s that Latin America
was moving to the left certainly was and
moved further and further to the left in
the 60s and 70s and this idea was was
cooked up between the head of the
University of Chicago Economics
Department and the head of the Chile
program for what became a USAID that
they would bring sponsor groups of
Chilean students to study at the
University of Chicago Economics
Department precisely because it was so
conservative and in fact in this time in
the 1950s it was seen as very you're
really outside the mainstream of
American economic discourse because you
know the United States was still in the
grips of Keynesianism Harvard yeah all
the Ivy League's were really Keynesian
had Keynesian economics department the
University of Chicago was different and
they had this program to bring
eventually hundreds of Latin American
students to study under Friedman and his
colleagues and that had a tremendous
impact on the politics of Latin America
because when they were a series of
military cooze in the 70s there was a
there were teams of economists that were
ready to work with those military
governments who didn't have any
expertise in economics so they formed a
kind of an alliance or a partnership but
with the military and these University
of Chicago trained economists how did
you research the Chilean connection Oh a
huge amount of research there but it
came this this research actually came
out of the fact that I had lived in
Argentina for for almost two years in I
went there at the end of 2001 and my
husband and I made a film called the
take about the economic crisis that hit
Argentina at the end of 2001
you are standing in front of ninety
million dollars worth of factories which
you and your company Rose have taken
over for your own benefit we have a word
for that it's called stealing
suppose a debonair against a profession
and this history you know was very
strong in Argentina so I learned I
learned about it from from what happened
in Argentina during the military coup
and from there I I learned about Chile
can you do a simple definition of the
difference between or define each one of
them Friedman follower believes this and
a cane Z canes follower believes this
well Keynesian ok Keynesian economist
believes in a mixed economy and it
definitely believes in a market economy
for you know all kinds of things
obviously for consumer goods but a
Keynesian economists sees a strong role
for government regulation many Keynesian
economists would see whole areas of the
economy that shouldn't be subject to the
market may be health care I mean there
isn't a canteen that kind of economics
is that it isn't a rulebook and this is
what makes it different than Friedman's
philosophy you know he you read
capitalism and freedom which is his sort
of manifesto it is a set of rules it's a
set of policy prescriptions this should
be privatized that should be privatized
so you know it's my it's a little bit
like apples and oranges to to to to
compare I believe because you don't have
like Keynesian disciples in that way
there are some rules like if you are in
an economic downturn if you're in an
economic recession you should spend your
way out of it counter cyclical
investments that's you know sort of the
clearest Keynesian rule where as a free
the Friedman philosophy and and and the
track record was in the midst of
economic crisis and this was done in
country after country they imposed
austerity measures so there was
contraction in the midst of of an
economic downturn and often just with
devastating human results if you go well
if you just watch this network for the
last couple years throughout this
financial crisis you can you know people
are pointing at each other saying you
did it you did it but when it comes to
this whole business of regulation you've
got people saying that we've always had
the laws in order to regulate but they
just weren't apply
and now people that's true I mean I
think in the 99 in the 1990s there was
there was a series of decisions that
were made that that deregulated the
financial sector that allowed banks to
to take on levels of debt that were that
were illegal beforehand you know so you
could have a situation like Bear Stearns
where they had a ratio of 33 to 1 of
debt to assets that was the result of a
deregulation decision there was an
extensive debate of that we now know
over whether or not to regulate
derivatives there were people like
Brooksley born who wanted to regulate
and then there was a pushback from alan
greenspan from larry summers who said no
we don't want to regulate derivatives so
the idea that there were rules but they
weren't applied no in this case there
was a concerted lobby not to have
regulations over this part of the
economy and an argument was made that it
could be self-regulating and that was
the fundamental flaw that alan greenspan
has since admitted to and then of course
there was the decision to do away with
glass-steagall which was the
depression-era law that prevented
commercial banks from also being
investment banks so that was a
deregulation decision so I I don't I
mean there certainly are cases of there
being laws on the books that are not
enforced but I think if we look at the
really key factors that led to this
particular economic crisis where you had
highly integrated financial institutions
that were allowed to grow too big to
fail that were allowed to carry huge
levels of debt and a sector that was
entirely outside the reach of regulators
that was not a case of the rules being
on the books and not being enforced that
was a case of a vision of deregulation
that was enforced in your introduction
the new introduction to no logo you talk
talking about the President Obama he
will slam the unacceptable greed of
banking executives even as he hands the
reins of the economy to consummate Wall
Street insiders well I mean what I'm
describing here about the key pieces of
deregulation that created the context
for this crisis
they were all clinton-era decisions they
were all when Larry Summers or Bob Rubin
was in charge of the US Treasury so the
fact that Larry Summers is now the most
influential economist in Washington to
me is very very troubling
Obama really won this election promising
to take on the ideology of deregulation
giving more and more to the people at
the top and waiting for it to trickle
down to the bottom you know I always
remember that Sarah Palin John McCain
were ahead of Obama after the Republican
convention they got their bump the
Democratic convention had been actually
pretty disappointed they barely got a
bump out of it and we were all looking
pretty seriously at a future of a
mccain-palin ticket winning and then
Lehman collapsed there was there was a
two-week period from when Sarah Palin
was introduced to the world on August
30th to when Lehman collapsed on
September 14th and after Lehman
collapsed Obama found his voice and he
started talking about how this financial
crisis was not the result of just one or
two you know bad apples but was the
result of an ideology of deregulation
that had gripped the United States for
eight years and that's where we that's
that's where he wasn't telling the truth
because it wasn't just the Bush years
and I think a lot of you know Democrats
and you know you talked about talking a
little bit about maybe what gives me a
little bit of a difference because a
different perspective because I'm I'm
you know I don't live in the US and I'm
much less partisan and I'm not you know
I'm not driven by it you know a desire
for Democrats to win elections that's
not you know what drives my writing and
you know I saw it just an incredible
amount of intellectual dishonesty from
liberals and progressives during that
election campaign where where we knew
damn well that that the key pieces of
legislation that created the context for
the economic crisis had been enacted
during the Clinton years but we knew
that this was you know a better
political message to claim that the
ideology was Bush policy was was just
the last eight years
the problem with intellectual dishonesty
is that it comes back to bite you
because if you are lying to yourselves
and everyone else during the election
campaign then what's to prevent a layer
summers from coming back and being given
you know the keys to the Treasury once
again what grade would you give media in
this country on this very issue
what grade well you know I I guess I
would say you know much improved but a
little late because I think that that
the the the the problem with the the US
economy is that it's been in this this
some cycle of bubbles and and busts and
and during the bubbles during the boom
times the the media in this country has
been an active participant in building
that hype I mean bubbles are all about
hype right and this is where I think
that holding the media accountable is
absolutely crucial you know Jon Stewart
was criticized for going after you know
Jim Cramer you know why pick on him but
of course pick on him because bubbles
are inflated with hot air right so who's
filling the hot air but the press I mean
that this is this is this is the job of
hype and and somebody like Jim Craig Jim
Cramer was you know a hot-air machine so
it's particularly relevant in analyzing
the politics of how you create a bubble
to hold the media accountable now in
retrospect there's been some absolutely
incredible investigative reporting by
the business press name name something
somebody well the New York Times
investigative team has has has been
absolutely incredible
why am I forgetting her name I'm Morgan
Moore
Gretchen Gretchen Morenstein I mean she
has done has done the I think some of
the best reporting and you know it the
piece that I think really changed
history was her finding out about the
battle over the regulate regulating
derivatives and introducing us to
Brooksley born who you know was the
whistleblower in the 90s and making the
argument for why we had to to to
regulate this industry and the pushback
that she got from Rubin and summers in
Greenspan that kind of but it's it's
retroactive you know we needed that
reporting at the time this is kind of
forensic reporting but I do think now
it's that there there there's there's
some really good work being done in in
in investigating the bailout
I think Huffington Post is doing some
really great stuff Sam Stein is doing
terrific research on lobbyists one of
the things I think is really important
that's going on now is is there's an
outing of lobbyists that lobbyists love
to work in the dark and to remain
anonymous and and and that is something
I think now that we know that the banks
are lobbying against much-needed reforms
using taxpayer dollars it's really made
them fair game and and and the lobbyists
are being you know dragged out of the
shadows we saw protests outside the
American Bankers Association meeting in
Chicago I think that's really important
because you know these are major power
players that really enjoy not facing
scrutiny the US Chamber of Commerce is
also facing some really unwanted
scrutiny and to be honest you know this
is one of the reasons why I wanted to
re-release no logo you know on this
anniversary it's not just because it
happens to be ten years it's because you
know the mood is is it is a bit of a no
logo moment I mean it is that that sort
of same anger at at the takeover of
public space in public institutions that
I was tracking in the book you know is
is back you know we're really with a
vengeance and and it seemed this seemed
like the timing was right the other book
and you mentioned the Shock Doctrine
what year did this come out it came out
in 2007 two years yeah yeah it was the
capsule what does this do and I know you
started off in the book talking to a
woman that has severe that had severe
mental problems well she yeah for a
reason I mean might just tell that story
as a kind of a metaphor for the book
well the book just the book is is a is
about different kinds of shock that's
why it's called a call the Shock
Doctrine but it's about the political
uses of shock and it came out of
reporting I did in Iraq and for Harper's
Magazine in 2004 I did a piece for
Harper's called Baghdad Year Zero
pillaging Iraq in pursuit of a neocon
utopia and
that piece was looking at how the
shock-and-awe attack on Iraq was
deliberately exploited by the bush team
that came in in the aftermath of the
invasion the civilian team the CPA to
push through what economists call
economic shock therapy which is
rapid-fire transformation pushed to a
free-market system we know it from the
Russian context you know the
transformation very very quickly from a
closed communist market to overnight
sort of a free market in in the case of
Russia and oligarchic arguably mafia
capitalism Joseph Stiglitz said that
what paul bremer tried to do in the
immediate aftermath of the shock and awe
invasion was an even more extreme
version of shock therapy than was
practiced in the former Soviet Union and
then I happened to be in Iraq also when
the first torture scandals broke when
they when the Abu Ghraib scandal broke
and I was trying to and I end the end of
the harpers peace with this trying to
understand what these different forms of
shock meant the shock and awe attack
followed by the economic shock therapy
and now suddenly these non-metaphorical
shocks being in the news the shocks on
bodies these of torture
so I started reading the declassified
CIA manuals about how to interrogate
what they call resistance sources people
that don't want to talk to you and the
manuals talk all about the need to put a
prisoner into a state of shock the fifth
one that when the prisoner goes into a
state of shock when they're totally
disoriented then they become pliant they
regress they go into a childlike state
and they're and they're much more likely
to cooperate with their interrogator and
when I read that I thought that in some
way it was a description of what I had
witnessed in Iraq that the idea was that
the strategy the war strategy was that
Iraq would be and this is a quote
actually in the book from Richard
Armitage old pals Undersecretary of
state he said the idea was that Iraqis
would be so shocked and so odd
they would be easily marshaled from
point A to point B and and point B in in
the vision of the Bush administration as
executed by Paul Bremer was that Iraq
would be this perfect free-market model
economy and if we cast our minds back to
2003 remember the the first summer of
Iraq under US occupation it was all
about the economic reforms Paul Bremer
was passing laws you know there seemed
to be a new one every day that allowed
foreign investors to come in on a
hundred percent of Iraq's assets he
announced the privatization of 200 of
Iraq state-owned companies Iraq actually
became Donald Rumsfeld said it has had
some of the most enlightened tax
policies in the world now this was all
done shock therapy style there was no
Iraqi government they didn't have to
negotiate they did it very quickly so it
I thought that I was seeing on in a
sense that they did on a mass scale what
happens to individuals in in in the
interrogation chamber that they're put
into a state of shock and then they're
bent to the will of their interrogator
and here this was a country that was put
into a state of shock and they attempted
to bend it to the will of their
occupiers and it didn't work it
backfired so that's why I start the book
with the story of a woman who underwent
extreme electroshock treatment as part
of these horrible CIA experiments in in
the 1950s as part of the MKULTRA program
do you and your family I don't wanna put
words your mouth but I just asked it
this way you can react to it every sit
around and say the Americans are getting
what they deserve well you know we never
talked that way because my parents
consider themselves American as well as
Canadian they are and they do maintain
their dual citizenship you vote you know
that so they would you know they
wouldn't say that and the Canadians
would you talk to him feel this way no
I'm as they look down on this country
and the Iraq war and all the things that
you talk about what's their attitude you
know I think there's so much goodwill in
the world about this country and you
know if you look at how much people want
to believe in in American Redemption
look at
excitement around the world in the face
of Obama's election I think you know
there's very little evidence that people
really wish Americans ill in fact
there's tremendous evidence that despite
many disappointments there's a
tremendous well of goodwill and and hope
and certainly that's true of Canada
there was Obama mania hit Canada pretty
hard and and and remains well what's
your take on the Obama administration
bringing these Guantanamo based
prisoners to this town New York City
having them tried here in a federal
court and then saying also it doesn't
matter whether they're guilty or not
guilty they're not going anywhere in
other words if they are found not guilty
they're not getting out well first of
all I do support the decision that they
be tried in the United States I think
Americans need to regain their faith and
their in their justice system without
exceptions this idea that you can have
these extrajudicial pockets where you
can send people you know for unlimited
amounts of time is utterly untenable
legally and morally it has to end and
you know I obviously is a painful
process politically and and and it's
painful you know to bring the system
back into lawfulness and it should you
know it's up to me I think what animal
should never have been opened in the
first place and I think it is very it's
it's a very very good sign that that
Obama is is doing this but yeah the last
part of it to say you know the results
don't matter you know as is undermining
that message and you know I think it's
kind of a typical it's it's it's a
typical Obama compromise actually where
he really undercuts himself by trying to
sort of split the difference and ending
up in a position that is hard to defend
I mean the thing about if there's
anything that we can learn from the
response the incredible response to
Obama from people like Glenn Beck and
now what we're hearing from Sarah Palin
on her book tour it's that no matter how
modest his reforms are
the attacks are going to be as if they
are the most radical reforms ever
attempted so here we have him being
called a socialist a fascist being
compared to Hitler they really haven't
left themselves anywhere to go like
after you've compared Obama to Hitler
where do you go after that so to me the
message seems to be that they may as
well stay true to their beliefs they may
as well introduce some thorough reforms
rather than these half measures and
endless compromises because then they're
going to have people that will really
really go to the wall and defend them
they keep making this mistake they did
it with health care that would they have
a health care plan where their
supporters don't know whether or not
they should support it they really don't
know that whether the public option is
strong enough and of course many of
Obama's supporters would support
single-payer you're the same thing
that's going to happen with the energy
bill where you know every serious
environmental group in this country
looks at both versions of this bill and
says the emission cuts are nowhere near
what the science demands the science is
very very clear so you know the you
can't really and you can't really
compromise or debate with with the
science so you end up with the app you
know the the full-on attack from the
right but your supporters are left
hanging because they don't actually have
something to rally behind and I think
it's bad politics another book soon from
you
well I've begun the long process let's
just say so what's what's the area what
what what are you doing this time it has
to do with them it has to do with debt
that's all I can say right now but it's
much more exciting than that what year
do you hope to publish it uh I'd say
it's it's two years away so are you on a
per capita basis more in demand in
Canada or in the United States to hear
your message um definitely in the United
States more than it more than anywhere
else which has really changed I mean
with no logo no logo was about a
bestseller around the world but not in
the United States in the United States
that was more of it was it was a you
know kind of a hit on university
campuses but it wasn't a best-seller
whereas in you know Canada was you know
number one bestseller Italy the United
Kingdom with the Shock Doctrine the
Shock Doctrine has sold better in the
United States than anywhere else and I
think it's you know it's it's the
political moment in this country